chers amis je suis très heureux bien
entendu d'avoir entendu marielle pour la
première fois depuis cinq mois dans nos
rangs et devant nos responsables et
militants c'est une journée particulière
pas seulement parce que c'est une
journée de congrès mais c'est un de ces
moments où les déchirures de la vie vous
atteignent vous oblige à revoir
l'histoire l'histoire collective et
notre histoire personnelle où l'émotion
nous fait revivre des moments précieux
et où la nostalgie nous enseigne le prix
des choses tout à l'heure ce matin
valéry giscard d'estaing a été porté en
terre auprès de sa fille et pour
quelques-uns d'entre nous ça est
évidemment une très grande émotion pour
marielle pour jacqueline pour moi c'est
une partie de notre vie une expérience
d'années d'engagement et de
compagnonnage et pour notre mouvement
dont je rappelle qu'il a été créé le
modem par une délibération de l'udf et
que l'association udf est toujours en
tant que telle partie prenante de ces
structures c'est un rendez vous un
rendez-vous d'émotions et de réflexions
alors il y avait l'homme la prestance
l'intelligence cartésienne lumineuse et
aussi l'audace des aventures bien eu le
président de deux français sur trois qui
a été en réalité on oublie trop souvent
populaire presque jusqu'au bout
vainqueur de justesse et vaincu de
justesse et pour nous il y eu avec lui
beaucoup de jeunesse beaucoup de culot
beaucoup de rires et des attachements
qu'il ne s'effaceront pas même quand des
divergences politiques apparaîtront
et puis il ya eu cette proposition
politique faite au pays et c'est le plus
important est de cette proposition
politique encore aujourd'hui nous sommes
les soutiens et les garants
cette proposition politique c'était le
refus de la france coupée en deux
c'était le pays gouverné au centre la
démocratie décrisper les droits de
l'opposition
la modernisation du pays une économie
puissante le tgv l'effort vers
l'indépendance énergétique la liberté
des prix une société réformer la
reconnaissance du droit des femmes le
divorce par consentement
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dépénaliser la promotion des femmes à
des postes de responsabilité l'élan
européen l'élection du parlement
européen au suffrage universel
le conseil européen la marche vers
l'euro
et pour le monde le g7 et pour notre
défense kolwezi
quel bilan en cette année et dans ce
bilan qui aujourd'hui y compris de ses
opposants acharnés de l'époque qui
aujourd'hui pourrait remettre en cause
une seule des décisions dont je viens de
faire la liste
dans son premier discours de président
de la république il y avait cette phrase
de ce jour date une ère nouvelle de la
politique française
cette promesse a été tenue et pour tous
ceux qui ont cru à cette promesse pour
tous ceux qui l'accompagnaient pour tous
ceux qui ont partagé cet élan il est
juste qu'il y ait si longtemps après à
l'endroit de valéry giscard d'estaing de
l'homme du président du combattant un
mouvement de gratitude peut pas faire
une minute de silence
mais on peut entendre la pensée émue et
reconnaissante qui est la nôtre et je
veux le dire aussi une pensée fidèles ce
que nous avons construit volontairement
sciemment avec emmanuel macron c'est le
même élan c'est le même projet c'est la
même jeunesse de l'époque c'est le même
courage pour porter des réformes
nécessaires
et c'est la même volonté de dépassement
des frontières archaïque et faut quand
même d'ajouter puisque nous faisons de
la politique il ya encore quelque chose
de commun c'est cette revendication de
rupture et l'exploit d'une élection
seul contre tous je mets le mot sonne au
pluriel parce que dans les deux cas nous
étions là avec le vainqueur est autour
de lui
c'est notre congrès le premier ministre
jean castex nous fera l'amitié de
s'exprimer après moi à la fin de ce
propos et je remercie tous ceux de nos
amis et alliés qui sont venus participer
au congrès soit 2 en marche soit de aj
reçoit thierry breton le commissaire
européen soit les ministres du
gouvernement les principaux qui se sont
exprimés je veux vous dire simplement
que je suis très fier de ce mouvement
politique que nous avons construit
ensemble et je suis sûr que vous qui
avez participé par centaines ou un peu
plus d'un millier toute la journée à ces
débats interactifs et virtuels mais
cette virtualité est aussi une réalité
je suis sûr que vous avez eu le
sentiment que c'était une grande
richesse que de que d'avoir entendu
d'avoir vu d'avoir senti autant des
nôtres s'exprimer aussi brillamment on
vient d'entendre marielle permettez moi
de citer les membres du gouvernement et
de signaler au passage que nos membres
du gouvernement sont quatre femmes et un
homme jacqueline gourault marc fesneau
geneviève darrieussecq nathalie et
limaces sarah l irene remercier patrick
mignola et les 58 maintenant député qui
forment notre groupe alors patrick m'a
appelé pour me faire des remontrances
parce que ce matin j'avais dit koné t55
alors nous sommes bien 58
je veux remercier nos douze sénateurs
nous permettrait de dire un mot de jean
marie van der m
r qui sert d'animateurs depuis longtemps
dans ce dans ce groupe du sénat
nos parlementaires européens
marie-pierre vedrenne catherine chabaud
sylvie brunet laurence farenc christophe
grudler et là encore de signaler que ces
quatre femmes et un homme je veux dire
que s'il ya un mouvement qui assure la
promotion féminine
nous sommes fiers d'être celui-là je
veux pas oublier non plus que marx max
orville et dans l'ordre de succession du
parlement européen le premier remplaçant
et on imagine où on espère que des
promotions ministérielles lui offriront
la place de siéger à strasbourg
je veux remercier notre secrétaire
général jean noël barrot
parce qu'il travaille beaucoup et très
bien et que je ne suis pas le seul à
m'en apercevoir et je veux remercier
jean noël la fée chacun chacune dans la
petite équipe vaillante de nos services
et tous les responsables de terrain et
vous tous qui êtes là vge nous a quitté
et il a été emporté
ça n'a pas beaucoup été dit par cette
maladie du coronavirus qui aura marqué
notre temps
cette épidémie qui a bouleversé le monde
et provoqué la crise la plus lourde que
la planète ait rencontré depuis la
guerre j'ai besoin de le dire mais
peut-être faut-il le marquer parce que
là encore l'actualité va plus vite et
fait peut-être adopter des points de vue
qui seraient pas exempts de cette crise
nous ne sommes pas sortis
alors bien sûr il ya les espoirs de
vaccins et ce serait pour nous tous une
magnifique nouvelle que l'année nouvelle
apporte avec elle
cette garantie de préservation pour
l'humanité mais de tout cela nous ne
sommes pas certains ni de l'efficacité
du vaccin contre la maladie ou la
transmission du virus ni de sa tolérance
ni de son administration aux patients et
nous ne sommes pas encore assuré de
l'adhésion des français à la vaccination
mais les conséquences en revanche nous
les découvrons tous les jours il faudra
des années peut-être davantage pour que
ses conséquences et face alors faut en
prendre la mesure
pour notre pays la perte sèche en
produit intérieur c'est plusieurs
centaines de milliards d'euros
et ce manque à gagner se cumulera avec
la même perte l'année prochaine pour
notre pays la dépense publique qui a
permis de soutenir les entreprises en
péril les salariés menacés de chômage
les plus fragiles par des aides directes
tout cela représente aussi plusieurs
centaines de milliards d'euros
supplémentaires le plan de relance et
les mesures de soutien sous des formes
diverses filières entreprises
collectivités
tout cela pèse aussi plus d'une centaine
de milliards
le gouvernement français a été de tous
les gouvernements du monde celui qui a
mobilisé le plus d'argent pour le plus
d'efforts de soutien de relance et de
solidarité alors comment avons nous pu
mobiliser de tels moyens pour consentir
un tel effort et comment adopter une
politique durable pour maîtriser le
cours de cet endettement dans les années
qui viennent et pour en sortir le jour
quand il viendra de la guérison
ce sont de graves et lourdes questions
que les français se posent et permettez
moi de les formuler en votre nom
moi qui ai mené tant de combats sur les
déficits et sur la dette
d'abord pour noter que si dans le passé
nous avions été plus cohérent comme
nation et particulièrement si les
gestionnaires de l'état avait été plus
conséquents à l'époque de ses combats
nous aurions eu aujourd'hui davantage de
moyens à mobiliser
et moins lourd de conséquences au moment
de la survenue de la crise mais il ya eu
deux bouleversements dans ce paysage qui
étaient pour beaucoup inattendue d'abord
il y a dix huit ans il s'est passé
quelque chose qu'on a un peu oublié sur
lequel on a glissé ses qui a 18 ans nous
avons remporté une grande victoire nous
avons remporté une grande victoire pour
nous mêmes mais aussi pour notre pays et
une victoire dont nous profitons
pleinement aujourd'hui car en 1992 grâce
et donc il y à 28 ans j'ai dit il ya 18
ans et il ya 28 ans grâce à l'effort
conjoint du gouvernement de françois
mitterrand et de la partie européenne de
l'opposition tout l'udf une partie du
rpr de l'époque les français ont décidé
après un intense débat et à une majorité
de 1% de d'abandonner pour ceux qui le
voudraient leur monnaie nationale est de
construire une monnaie unique pour
l'europe l'euro et de se doter d'une
banque centrale européenne on se
demandait tout à l'heure pourquoi cet
effort est possible et bien la réponse
est que c'est parce que nous avons cet
outil crédible unique à la surface de la
planète que nous pouvons consentir un
tel effort mais je voudrais poser une
question où en serions nous aujourd'hui
si dans cette crise ce 1% de majorité
d'il ya 28 ans avait manqué
si nous n'étions pas entrer dans cet
espace de stabilité de protection que
nous garantit une des grandes banques
centrales de la planète est bien la
vérité que nous serions forcés
d'emprunter sous la surveillance des
marchés et forcément incapables de
mobiliser les sommes immenses que
requiert la crise et nous subirions les
assauts de la spéculation qui parmi les
opposants de l'époque voudrait
aujourd'hui s'avancer devant les
français aient affirmé
nous devons sortir de l'euro et
reprendre à notre compte solitairement
les emprunts que requiert cette crise où
sont ils
les critiques et les contempteurs comme
on dit et les prophètes de l'éclatement
de notre union où les ententes ont en
réalité je vais vous dire un secret ils
ne veulent qu'une chose c'est qu'on
oublie leurs déclarations d'hier puis un
deuxième élément dans ce changement qui
a permis cet effort c'est qu'il s'est
passé à la surface de la planète une
révolution intellectuelle
une révolution de doctrine qui fait que
les politiques économiques et
financières des grands ensembles du
monde ont changé jusque là on vivait sur
la solidité du bon sens
l'argent était emprunté à un taux qui
était à peu près proportionnelle aux
risques encourus par l'emprunteur et
puis si le risque était faible les taux
étaient bas si le risque était fort les
taux étaient au et c'était des
politiques qui n'aimait pas trop le
risque qui avait la crainte constante de
l'inflation dont on a vécu toutes les
difficultés après la guerre c'était des
politiques on appelle conventionnel mais
s'est passé quelque chose c'est que la
banque centrale américaine la première
parce qu'elle a dans son mandat et c'est
très important et je me suis beaucoup
battu pour que nous y réfléchissions
nous pour nous les européens la banque
centrale américaine elle a dans son
mandat dans ses obligations dans ses
engagements non seulement la défense de
la monnaie mais aussi le plein emploi et
en raison de cette obligation
ceux qui pensent la politique monétaire
américaine sont entrés de plain pied
dans une démarche dont très peu ont
saisi l'audace qui est en vérité une
politique de rupture en inventant une
politique non conventionnelle
garantissant publiquement officiellement
qu'elle était prête à soutenir
l'économie américaine
quoi qu'il en coûte et jusqu au plein
emploi
il ya peu d'observateurs par mais parmi
les non spécialistes qui ont perçu ce
tournant et c'était pourtant une
révolution qui a conduit à une baisse
générale des taux sur la planète
alan pratiquement jusqu'à des taux zéro
parfois à des taux négatifs on vous
verse un intérêt pour que vous
empruntiez et qui a créé ad politique de
création monétaire très abondante tous
azimuts
alors pendant longtemps les classiques
lait conventionnel on en connaît
beaucoup on dit ça ne pourra pas durer
et pourtant la vérité du moment à
l'encontre de ce qu'on croit être le bon
sens spontanée comme on le ressent c'est
que tout indique que ça va durer il se
trouve donc qu'au moment même où la
traversée de la crise requiert des
sommes immenses d'argent public
les banques centrales permettent que des
crédits à 0% irriguent notre économie
c'est une situation il faut que vous
vous en souveniez pour les plus âgés
pour les plus jeunes c'est une situation
qui ne s'est jamais rencontré dans
l'histoire du monde
alors est ce que c'est est ce que cette
situation et sans risque
je vais vous dire franchement non ya des
risques et nul ne sait vraiment comment
maîtriser ces risques
le premier de ces risques c'est que ça
creuse les inégalités entre les plus
riches et les plus pauvres entre ceux à
qui on peut prêter parce qu'ils ont
notamment de très grosses fortunes et
les autres il ya donc un creusement en
raison de cette situation prenait terre
il ya des creusements d'inégalités qui
sont considérables et si vous regardez
le cours des affaires que vous pouvez
lire dans les journaux économiques alors
vous allez voir qu'il ya de très grandes
acquisitions
qui sont consentis par de très grande
puissance financière et qui sont en
réalité oui en effet un accroissement
des inégalités
alors il ya des risques mais à l'heure
présente convenons-en thierry breton le
disais tout à l'heure il ya aussi des
avantages
et c'est un monde pour une fois
l'expression est juste c'est un monde
nouveau
alors cette disponibilité inédite de
l'argent presque gratuit nous permet de
passer un cap
mais elle ne nous dispense pas d'ouvrir
les yeux sur ce que la crise nous a fait
découvrir de nos faiblesses
alors je vais en énoncer quelques unes
nous avons découvert que nous france qui
nous vivons comme un grand pays nous
nous étions laissés aller jusqu'à
devenir sur des produits essentiels et
même vitaux dépendant de production et
de livraison sur lesquels nous n'avions
pas la main nous avons découvert par
exemple que sur les médicaments
essentiels ceux qui permettent de lutter
contre le cancer ce qu'ils sont des
antibiotiques des anti inflammatoires
des médicaments pour les anesthésies des
molécules pour les anesthésies et puis
simplement le paracétamol que chacun a
dans sa pharmacie
nous étions menacés d'être en rupture de
fourniture est donc cette crise là elle
a révélé notre dépendance est notre
premier devoir dans cette crise et avec
à l'esprit le fait qu il peut y en avoir
d'autres
ou que probablement il est malade il y
en aura d'autres alors ça c'est crise
notre premier devoir est de garantir
notre indépendance et notre sécurité
on l'a fait dans d'autres domaines on le
fait admirablement avec nos forces
armées
l'armée française est aujourd'hui je
crois sans discussion la première armée
européenne
et donc il faut le faire aussi dans le
domaine économique et des productions
nous devons le faire en définissant les
filières stratégiques et les productions
clé qui garantissent aux français leur
sécurité leurs capacités technologiques
nous avons découvert une deuxième chose
que je veux reprendre avec vous parce
que ça va nous ouvrir des obligations
des devoirs et des missions c'est que
nous avons découvert que la france et
son modèle social sont fragiles j'ai
rappelé que service de notre solidarité
à l'égard des entreprises des salariés
des familles dans la crise nous avons
dépensé reprenant les mêmes mots que la
banque centrale américaine nous avons
dépensé quoi qu'il en coûte
et donc c'est à constituer une dette
qu'ovide très importante et je veux
m'arrêter une seconde à cette idée parce
que un grand nombre de français qui nous
écoutent particulièrement parmi ceux qui
nous ont suivi quand on menait le combat
juste contre la dette à l'époque un très
grand nombre de français n'y voit plus
clair dans cette question de l'argent
qui paraît sortir de nulle part
comment va-t-on gérer la sortie de cet
endettement et moi je veux répondre
clairement à cette question proposer une
réponse en votre nom est propre aux
méthodes cette dette que vide elle a une
caractéristique c'est qu' elle n'est pas
la dette de notre responsabilité
le virus est venu d'ailleurs et personne
ne sait d'où et je ne crois pas pour ma
part qu'on puisse en affecter la
responsabilité à qui que ce soit donc
cette dette qu'ovide il faut l'isoler du
reste de notre endettement
la cantonner définir précisément quelles
sont les sommes qui ont été dépensées
pour la crise du coc vide et qu'on
n'aurait pas dépensé autrement et il
faut annoncer que c'est que cette dette
nous la rembourseront mais avec ce qu'on
fait quand on achète une maison ou un
appartement avec un différé de
remboursement jusqu'au moment où notre
pays se sera redressée mais nous la
rembourseront dans cinq ans dans huit
ans dans dix ans et sur une longue
période
sur 25 ans sur 30 ans sur 40 ans
pourquoi pas mais nous la remboursement
nous la rembourseront pourquoi alors je
lis quelques fois que des esprits rapide
des personnalités ou des forces
politiques imagine qu'on pourrait
purement et simplement supprimé la dette
et je veux dire pour être véridique que
naturellement ces temps leur et c'est un
leurre pour une raison simple parce
qu'un pays qui ne rembourserait pas sa
dette ne pourrait plus jamais emprunté y
compris pour investir et le en même
temps quoi qu'il en coûte ça ne veut pas
dire que ça ne coûte pas ça veut dire
que nous ne mesurons pas l'effort au
service de ceux qui sont en première
ligne
mais on le voit bien et c'est aussi une
leçon pour nous ce modèle social ne peut
être garantie que si les financer et il
ne peut être financé que si nous
resterons notre capacité économique à
l'égard des pays les plus avancés au
monde et ce défi pour nous nous l'avons
repérée depuis longtemps
il ya quelques années nous avons fait
une campagne présidentielle ensemble
sous le slogan produire en france et ce
slogan à l'époque portait à sourire les
plus savants et les plus brillants
aujourd'hui restauré notre appareil
productif
c'est une question de survie
il n'y a pas de modèle social performant
s'il n'y a pas de modèle économique à la
hauteur et la production du pays qu'elle
soit intellectuel industriels agricoles
et les services autour du conte assume
seul le financement
de la protection sociale qui est le vrai
contrat social du pays
et quand on laisse partir les produits
en réalité on laisse partir la recherche
on laisse partir
la réflexion on laisse partir le
marketing et dont nous avons besoin de
restaurer tout cela parce que ça c'est
en france terriblement affaibli je veux
vous donner un seul chiffre
j'abuse rep à l'industrie en allemagne
c'est 25% du produit intérieur
l'industrie en france et 13%
la moitié est encore dans la mécanique
dans l'aéronautique dans l'énergie c'est
à dire les fleurons de notre industrie
la crise a fait que des fragilités
nouvelle nous sont imposées dans dans la
voiture dans l'aéronautique par exemple
et que donc nous n'avons pas seulement à
sauvegarder notre économie mais nous
avons à relancer nous avons à
reconstruire et vous me permettrez de
dire au passage que c'est pour moi dans
la mission du plan qui m'a été confiée
par le président de la république c'est
une obsession et un engagement de chaque
instant je voudrais aborder une deuxième
grande question qui taraude les français
c'est la grande question de la sécurité
et de la sécurité en rapport avec les
libertés c'est fascinant de voir comme
toujours dans les grands débats du pays
c'est les grandes questions de principe
qui reviennent alors je veux dire ceci
je le dis le passage que je vais
consacrer à la sécurité je le dis aussi
en pensant aux manifestations
inacceptables qui ont lieu à cet instant
dans paris en particulier etc ces images
là que j'ai devant les yeux quand je
défends ses principes
je défends les deux principes les deux
impératifs que nous connaissons nous
sommes et nous devons être intraitables
sur la sécurité et nous sommes
naturellement intraitable sur les
libertés
et aussi on y réfléchit la démocratie
c'est ce qui permet de concilier les
deux nous ne pouvons pas vivre sans
sécurité sur l'épidémie sur l'ordre
public sur la lutte contre le terrorisme
la sécurité est un impératif catégorique
qui ne se discute pas et que ce qui se
discute d'autant moins que la sécurité
c'est d'abord la sécurité des plus
fragiles des plus économiquement faibles
des plus âgés et cela nous savons bien
que ça n'est pas une liberté que de
casser des vitrines ou pire encore comme
ils disent que de casser du flic
la sécurité c'est une liberté et les
commerçants des avenues de paris de
certains centres villes de province qui
samedi après samedi voient leurs
vitrines explosées leurs fichiers jetés
sur le trottoir
quelles responsabilités on ti pourquoi
les cibles ton quelle est la
justification de cette violence eh bien
il n'y a qu'une justification aucune
raison en tout cas c'est que le désordre
pour cela est une fin en soi le désordre
n'est pas un accident c'est le désordre
qu'il vise
et ces femmes et ces hommes je pense aux
commerçants qu'ils ont des obligations
des charges de famille ils ont des
familles et c'est une responsabilité
sociale et même une responsabilité de
droit que de ne pas laisser faire ces
désordres
je veux évoquer les mots d'ordre qui
sont inacceptables intolérables
d'agressions contre les policiers
les policiers ce sont nos forces de
sécurité ce sont nos forces de sécurité
à tous ceux qui les ciblent nos cibles
et ce ne sont pas des privilégiés pour
la plupart comme on dit ce sont des fils
du peuple des enfants de milieux sans
privilèges
ils ont franchi un degré de l'échelle
méritocratique en s'engageant comme ils
s'engagent et ils ne sont pas protégés
ils n'ont pas à l'être contre leurs
propres erreurs il on a respecté une
déontologie exigeante qui justifie de
dures sanctions en cas de manquement
alors quand des gens qui profitent de
ces manifestations pour assouvir leurs
instincts très souvent des gens
installés dans la vie très souvent des
bourgeois comme on dit et pas toujours
jeunes qui regardent les policiers en
face qui leur cri suicidez vous et bien
cela ce n'est pas par préférence mais
c'est de notre devoir qu'on leur dise
notre condamnation d un et notre soutien
des autres en les soutenant
quand ils sont si violemment agressé
comme cette jeune femme commissaire de
police qui a été blessé cette semaine en
manifestation en les soutenant
on ne justifie rien des violences
inacceptables par exemple contre michel
nucléaire et qui doivent être punis
comme tel comme inacceptable on défend
des principes dont la conciliation et la
raison d'être de notre droit et de notre
démocratie c'est être présent auprès de
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin que de
défendre la sécurité de tous et la
sécurité de tous ne se défend qu'avec
une organisation de la société et des
forces de sécurité qui mérite le soutien
de tous ceux qui sont attentifs aux
injustices je voudrais aborder troisième
chapitre je voudrais aborder la question
de la démocratie dans le monde de 2021
vers lequel nous allons l'état de la
démocratie n'est pas rassurant
la démocratie qui devrait être le
respect des droits et du droit est mise
en cause par la manière dont le débat
s'organise par la cataracte de haine qui
se donne libre cours sur les réseaux
sociaux la démocratie qui devrait être
peso préservation de la raison est
déstabilisée par les fanatismes par les
superstitions parler complotisme et par
la mise en cause de plus en plus
ouvertes de la science et les vérités
les mieux établies la démocratie qui est
culture du compromis du respect des
opinions différentes du travail en
commun qui dépasse ou est appelée à
dépasser les divergences démocratie est
assailli par les stratégies électorales
fondé sur l'affrontement systématique et
la culture de la peur et la démocratie
qu'est par nature pluraliste et bannie
dans une immense partie du monde
aujourd'hui au profit de systèmes de
domination qui veulent tout dirigé et
tout contrôle et des individus et des
groupes
et donc la démocratie est affaiblie de
l'intérieur est attaquée de l'extérieur
alors est ce que je puis dire en même
temps que je la défends que nous ne
savons pas où nous ne savons plus faire
marcher la démocratie est probablement
chez nous en france sont nos plus
fragile de ce point de vue là que dans
d'autres pays européens en particulier
alors pourquoi la concomitance de
l'élection présidentielle et des
élections législatives fait que
l'habitude ces prises que dans notre
pays le pouvoir bascule est brutalement
d'un bord sur l'autre tout le pouvoir à
ceux qui gagnent et plus rien même si
l'on réunit des millions de citoyens à
ceux qui ont perdu l'élection majeure or
garantir le pluralisme n'est pas
seulement une question de justice
pacifier la société parce que quand le
pluralisme est respectée on apprend à se
parler on apprend discuter on apprend à
s'écouter et les passions recul pour
laisser la place à un débat et à des
décisions qui sont prises dans des
mécanismes reconnu par tout le monde
c'est pourquoi je veux dire où répéter
parce que ça a été dit beaucoup dans la
journée puis que nous le disons depuis
longtemps je veux dire et répéter que la
question de la loi électorale et
centrale particulièrement dans un pays
comme le nôtre où l'élection du
président de la république au suffrage
universel concentre beaucoup de pouvoirs
entre les mains de l'élu et confie donc
en même temps un seul homme la
responsabilité de l'orientation du pays
alors il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent
mais votent la loi électorale on consent
à dire qu'elle est juste votre la loi
électorale que vous défendez la loi
électorale de justice on veut bien dire
qu'elle est juste mais il ya des risques
épouvantable de revenir à la quatrième
république
je veux vous dire que c'est absurde
parce que ces risques là les
institutions de la vème république les
ont banni une fois pour toutes
et donc nous devons comprendre que ces
risques n'existent plus et qu'il faut
essayer au contraire de retrouver les
avantages de ce pluralisme
d'abord parce que c'est un rééquilibrage
nécessaire de la légitimité et parce que
c'est je le disais le seul moyen
d'apprendre aux courants différents à se
parler à s'écouter et à échapper aux
affrontements caricaturaux et il n'y a
pas de risques parce que le président de
la république élu au suffrage universel
à lui tous les moyens d'empêcher que les
divisions ou les désordres n'empêche
l'action publique d'agir
il a le droit
d'opposer ou en tout cas d'obliger à
respecter ses engagements dans dans la
préparation de la loi il à la menace de
dissoudre l'assemblée nationale
il a le référendum il a la possibilité
de s'adresser au pays et donc tout ce
que le général de gaulle a conçu c'est
qu'on puisse avoir le pluralisme et en
même temps la garantie que ce risque
n'existera plus et d'ailleurs ceux qui
veulent s'en convaincre il suffit qu'ils
relisent le texte fondateur de la vème
république beaucoup plus anciens plus de
dix ans avant la création de la vème
république qui s'appelle le discours de
bayeux et au discours de bayeux le
général de gaulle explique exactement
son idée son idée tant qu' on va faire
échapper les gouvernements et l'exécutif
aux manoeuvres parlementaires c'est le
mot qu'il emploie et que le président de
la république élu au suffrage universel
s'était pas encore le suffrage universel
mais c'était l'idée que le président de
la république composerait son
gouvernement
écoutez bien cette phrase en tenant
compte des nuances de l'assemblée
nationale il dit pas en fonction de la
majorité de l'assemblée nationale il dit
en tenant compte des nuances de
l'assemblée et c'est une dérive à
laquelle on s'est livré que de croire
qu'en réalité c'est la majorité de
l'assemblée qui doit former le
gouvernement
il suffit de relire les textes
fondateurs pour comprendre que nous
avons dérivé et glissé depuis un certain
temps il ya un deuxième problème c'est
que nous ne savons même plus organisée
l'expression du suffrage
j'entendais tout à l'heure patrick ou
marc dire que on n'avait pas réfléchi à
ces à la progression de l'abstention aux
élections municipales
parce que tout le monde s'est laissé
entraîner à penser que l'abstention aux
élections municipales c'était le virus
et possiblement il est possible que cet
été le cas au premier tour mais au
second tour s'était pas du tout ça c'est
que l'abstention notamment dans les
villes importantes et est un symptôme
est un symptôme grave
c'était soit le désintérêt soit le
sentiment d'inutilité du vote soit
l'indifférence à l'enjeu comme si les
citoyens
voyez très bien que leur cadre de vie
était important et que ça les
intéressait mais ne voyait plus le lien
direct entre le vote et le cadre de vie
et c'est pourquoi nous militons et je
parle en particulier aux parlementaires
de notre mouvement nous militons pour
une ouvre une ouverture à d'autres modes
d'expression du suffrage vote par
correspondance ou vote par internet qui
ne remplacerait pas le vote dans l'urne
et dans l'isoloir
mais qui s'ajouteraient aux votes en
présence ou vote par procuration je suis
moi stupéfait quand on voit qu aux etats
unis ce sont plus de 100 millions de
suffrages
entendez bien plus de 100 millions de
suffrages qui ont été exprimés par
correspondance sans qu'à l'heure qu'il
est en dépit des des soubresauts de
monsieur trump et des plaintes partie
fille ciel on n'a pas pu jusqu'à ce jour
trouvé une seule anomalie dans
l'organisation du vote
alors on voit bien que les critiques qui
chez nous font j'allais dire la fine
bouche sont à mon avis déplacé en
allemagne les élections municipales ont
ils eu en même temps que notre premier
tour et elles ont pu se tenir parce
qu'elle était sous forme ou en tout cas
offrant aux citoyens les votes par
correspondance
en suisse les consultations recueil
souvent plus de 90% des voix qui
s'expriment ainsi j'ai jamais entendu
dire qu'il y avait des risques sur la
démocratie suisse jean noël et donc je
veux simplement répéter cela on a besoin
d'une modernisation
on a besoin d'une ouverture et j'engage
les parlementaires de notre mouvement à
se saisir de ces questions sans timidité
parce que je suis sûr qu'il ya là un
moyen d'augmenter la participation
citoyenne
je voudrais aborder un chapitre
supplémentaire dans cette difficulté de
notre démocratie et dans ce que nous
pouvons apporter
j'ai je veux traiter de la question de
l'association de la société civile à la
délibération politique je m'adresse en
particulier avec amitié à marc fesneau
qu'il ya une partie de cette union
l'essentiel de cette responsabilité au
gouvernement je vais partir de ce qu'on
a vécu
j'ai été frappée du débat qu'il y a eu
sur l'organisation du culte dans les
églises tout le monde sait ce que je
pense est ce que je pense de la jauge
fixé à 30 que je jugeais comment dire
assez peu logique parce que 30 dans une
chapelle et rentrent dans une cathédrale
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
or il se trouve qu'une décision dans des
domaines de cette horde une décision
contraignante
chaque fois qu'on le peut il faut
qu'elle apparaisse logique d'abord à
ceux qui devront la respecter et
probablement utile était plus naturel
mais nous ne savons pas bien faire ça en
france de définir une telle décision
avec les principaux intéressés n'ont pas
seulement dans un dialogue discret ou
secrets dans une antichambre ou au
téléphone mais il ya aucun inconvénient
ce qu'un dialogue public permettent de
deux de fixer des règles de cet ordre
alors j'ai j'ai choisi dans le
commissariat au plan de prendre le
conseil que le mix social et
environnemental comme parthenay
parce que le conseil économique social
et environnemental c'est la chambre de
la société civile organisée alors ça
n'est pas la seule il peut y en avoir
d'autres
mais je suis sûr que nous pouvons faire
mettre des modes de préparation de la
décision publique dans lesquels les
principaux intéressés soit directement
associés consultés et que ce soit avec
eux qu'on construise on dit aujourd'hui
qu'on construise la décision je veux
aborder comme une obligation là aussi la
question de l'environnement
la question de l'environnement elle dit
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
est que je crois les plus jeunes d'entre
nous ressemblent très bien c'est que
nous sommes responsables du monde et il
ya deux grandes questions devant nous la
première c'est la protection de la
biodiversité et l'autre c'est la
question de l'énergie
je suis très fier que ce soit l'un
d'entre nous yann wehrling qui soit
chargée pour représenter la france de
cette responsabilité de défense et de
promotion de la biodiversité c'est une
ligne de responsabilité à l'égard de nos
enfants et à l'égard de la planète dont
nous avons la charge
il est de notre responsabilité est de
notre devoir
je le dis pour les trois ans qui
viennent puisque cette élection elle
ouvre une nouvelle période
il est de notre responsabilité de notre
devoir d'être en première ligne devant
la défense et la promotion de la défense
et de la promotion de la biodiversité et
de la même manière la question du climat
elle se concentre sur la baisse continue
et volontaires pour un pays comme le
nôtre suivant nos engagements en
particules
et la baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre c'est un geste de
responsabilité et c'est un geste
d'exemplarité
je suis les débats qu'il y a dans les
autres pays européens sur cette question
et ses débats se concentrent aujourd'hui
sur le remplacement le plus vite
possible ou assez vite des moteurs
thermiques par des équipements
électriques / sur les voitures ou en
tout cas sur les poids lourds ce qui
veut dire que la question de la
production électrique va être là aussi
en première ligne elle va dominer les
débats sur l'énergie et la question de
la production électrique décarbonée
c'est à dire énergie solaire énergie
hydroélectrique et il faut avoir le
courage de le dire l'énergie nucléaire
en france
nous avons pris une avance sur tous les
pays du monde sur la production
d'énergie sans rejets de gaz à effet de
serre et un certain nombre d'entre nous
rêvent que nous nous effacions de ce
champ de compétence
j'étais très heureux que hier dans son
interview à brut
le président de la république rappelle
cette évidence là il ya là quelque chose
qui est une responsabilité pour nous
tous et c'est une responsabilité que
nous ne devons pas éludée ça veut dire
aussi que faut travailler pour certains
sur les batteries pour d'autres sur
l'hydrogène et nous devons assumer de
dire la vérité non pas de nous échapper
comme trop souvent ça arrive et un
sondage qui disait récemment que les
français croyaient que c'était les
centrales nucléaires qui était à 80 %
responsable du rejet de gaz à effet de
serre alors faut simplement dire pour
que tout le monde l'entende que
centrales nucléaires zéro rejets de gaz
à effet de serre
au rejet c'est la manière la plus
protectrice contre les rejets de gaz à
effet de serre pas dit qu'il n'avait pas
d'inconvénient il y en a partout mais au
moins si nous voulons une politique
cohérente en matière d'énergie si nous
voulons une politique cohérente en
matière d'environnement
alors il faut que nous la bâtissions sur
des principes solides et c'est une des
forces de la france il n'y a aucune
raison d'abandonner cette force là je
voudrais dire un mot de notre mouvement
en dernier point je suis très heureux de
ce que nous avons fait et je suis très
heureux en particulier de la force de
cette équipe et du caractère
transgénérationnels comme on dit de ceux
qui la forme nous avons pris soin tous
ensemble que soient représentés ou soit
accède à la responsabilité des femmes et
des hommes j'ai dit qu'il y avait
presque plus de femmes que d'hommes des
femmes et des hommes de générations
différentes de ceux qui ont mené les
combats
j'en suis de ceux qui les assument
aujourd'hui génération par exemple de
marc fesneau de ceux qui ont commencé à
les mener occupent des responsabilités
les les plus jeunes membres du
gouvernement et les plus jeunes membres
de notre équipe je regardais sarah
j'aurais pu regarder nathalie je regarde
jean noël nous avons pris soin
d'équilibrer la représentation et de
faire monter autant que nous le pouvions
des vocations nouvelles et des talents
nouveaux sais pas si comme moi vous avez
été frappée d'écouter les débats et de
voir à quel point le
la réflexion les ans la capacité
d'expression et est désormais réparti
parmi tous les responsables qui ont
accédé récemment aux responsabilités et
donc de ce point de vue là c'est une
grande fierté jeu j'ai une attente qui
n'a pas été satisfaite alors je regarde
tous ceux qui ont travaillé avec moi il
y a quinze ans au moins que je me bats
pour que nous inventions un nouveau
militantisme
alors je m'adresse à tous ceux qui sont
de de l'autre côté de cet écran je suis
persuadé que nous devons changer la
forme de l'engagement l'engagement
classique adhésion cotisations
fédération départementale c'est un
engagement qui a sa valeur mais je pense
qu'il faut que nous imaginions là aussi
d'autres formes d'engagement je plaidais
pour d'autres formes d'expression du
suffrage je suis pour que nous ayons
d'autres formes d'engagement et alors je
m'adresse soucier des messages
personnels que tous les responsables de
notre mouvement entendront j'ai la
détermination que nous bâtissions tout
de suite la fédération internet que
j'appelle de mes voeux depuis longtemps
parce que beaucoup d'entre nous ne sont
pas en contact d'une organisation
départementale qui souvent siège où
s'exprime depuis le chef lieu ils ont
par fait le droit parfaitement le droit
de participer au débat de se faire
entendre et je garantis que dans les
allées on est au mois de décembre que
avant la fin de l'hiver
nous aurons une fédération internet
exemplaires un mode de participation au
débat exemplaire et je voudrais que nous
réfléchissions ensemble aux étapes
différentes et complémentaires qui
détermine l'engagement très souvent on
s'engage sans savoir très bien où on va
très souvent on s'engage sans avoir la
certitude que c'est le bon mouvement
politique les bonnes méthodes qu'on sera
respectée les gens ont peur par exemple
que quand on adhère on ne soit plus
libre
or suffit qu'il fasse un stage dans nos
rangs pour vérifier que savait pas parce
qu'on adhère qu'on est plus libre tout à
fait au contraire donc le je suis je
suis sérieux en disant que c'est une
obligation pour nous qui avons
l'habitude
j'allais presque dire historique de
l'engagement politique des débats
traditionnels classiques conventionnelle
et ils ont toute leur valeur
mais très souvent je rencontre des
jeunes qui me disent vous voulez pas
nous raconter comment ça s'est construit
tout ça il faut qu'on le fasse et il
faut que se sente chez nous des
personnes des femmes et des hommes et
des jeunes qu'ils sentent qu'ils
partagent quelque chose avec nous sans
être sûre de vouloir aller tout de suite
au bout d'un engagement politique
un engagement progressif qui respecte la
liberté et les choix de chacun et qui
innove en matière de débat en matière
des changes comme nous avons innové
aujourd'hui voilà les quelques mots je
voulais dire pour notre congrès pour en
tout cas
les mois que nous allons vivre alors
vous avez tous compris que c'est une
grande mission qui est devant nous c'est
une grande mission qui est devant le
président de la république il a une
lourde charge
il a des qualités hors du commun pour
les assumer
mais il a aussi rencontré des obstacles
hors du commun
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait eu une
période un président de la république
récente en tout cas dans la vème
république qui est connu autant de
crises en si peu de temps et de crise
qui mettait en cause l'unité la solidité
du pays et donc le président et la
majorité présidentielle doivent assumer
dans les temps qui sont difficiles la
promesse de renouveau qui est celle de
c'est une lourde responsabilité devant
le gouvernement
et je m'adresse en particulier au
premier ministre qui va me succéder à
cette tribune est et à nos amis
ministres devant le gouvernement parce
qu'il doit affronter au présent et au
futur
un défi on l'a dit sanitaire économique
social démocratique sans précédent et
assumer en même temps l'engagement
environnemental qui a été le nôtre c'est
une grande responsabilité devant nous
mouvement politique parce que nous
portons quelque chose qui est infiniment
précieux et dont on l'a dit est
infiniment discuter qui porte les
valeurs les plus profondes de la
démocratie alors que cette aspiration à
la conscience et à la responsabilité est
mise au défi comme elle ne l'a jamais
été et donc nous devons inventer en un
temps inédits de nouvelles réponses et
c'est une lourde responsabilité devant
nous tous ensemble qui formons le peuple
français
parce que nous avons deux choses à faire
en même temps je souris en prononçant
ces trois mots nous avons en même temps
à corriger les insuffisances et les
erreurs passées et à construire pour
l'avenir un modèle de société à vocation
universelle comme c'est la mission de la
france de la concevoir de la pensée et
de commencer à la réaliser parce que
c'est cela qu'il faut comprendre je
crois quand on regarde l'histoire et la
réalité profonde de notre pays
la france ne peut pas être elle même si
elle ne se projette pas dans l'avenir
avec des valeurs valeurs qui rendent son
projet unique de ces des valeurs morales
cd liberté égalité fraternité ces trois
exigences morales des valeurs morales
des valeurs sociales des valeurs de
liberté de créativité
la france ne peut être elle même que
ayant charge d'âmes charge de famille
charge d'entreprise besoin de prospérité
et d'emplois
elle se bat tous les jours en gardant
les yeux fixés sur un idéal universel
qui est de justice de liberté et de
responsabilité
c'était un beau congrès inédit par sa
forme
je remercie ceux qui ont organisé je
vous remercie d'y avoir participé
même à distance mais pas de manière
virtuelle à distance mais réellement
merci à tous